notre érable est à l'honneur et cette
fois ci ce n'est pas le sirop qui attire
l'attention mélo deux produits québécois
se sont récemment distingué sur la scène
internationale d'abord la vodka white
qu'ils produite à montréal a remporté le
titre masters la plus haute distinction
dans leur catégorie à la compétition de
vodka master's tenue à londres
elle est composée à 50 6 % d'eau de sève
d'érable
une façon de valoriser cette eau qui est
normalement jetés par les acériculteurs
puis l'eau d'érable m'impose 3 s'est
quant à elle tend une place en finale du
concours qui récompense les meilleurs au
monde
une eau aromatisée qui s'inscrit dans la
famille des au végétal l'eau d'érable
gagne des adeptes ici mais aussi
ailleurs dans le monde comme en france
au japon et en australie
l'industrie acéricole affirme que le
potentiel de l'eau d'érable est presque
aussi important est celui du sirop
d'érable